The grand jury
in Manhattan is back to work today.
But Donald Trump is not
not on the docket.
The jury may resume
work on the Trump hush
money case as soon as Monday,
but today's break underlines
a moment of reassessment
for the Manhattan D.A.
Sources telling CNN
prosecutors might want
to bring in another witness.
That witness might be Michael Cohen,
the former Trump lawyer and fixer.
But it also, we are told, might not be
Michael Cohen that pores
leaving a void,
the former president eager to fill
with all caps,
rants, shouting
he has committed no crime
and that this is a witch hunt.
Begin our coverage in New York
with CNN's Kara Scannell.
Kara, so the grand jury, not Trump today.
What do we know
Yeah, John.
So as you
said, the grand jury is meeting today,
but they will not be hearing
any evidence
related to the investigation into Trump's
alleged role in the hush money
payments scheme.
Now, grand juries hear
multiple cases,
so it's really not a surprise
that they would be hearing another case
that could have been
just a scheduling issue.
We do know this grand jury has
that on Monday
Wednesdays and Thursdays,
and that is when they have heard
witness testimony,
the witnesses that have come
in, including Michael Cohen,
including the former editor
of The National Enquirer, David Pecker,
They have come in on Monday,
Wednesday and Thursday.
But we do also know that
they are next
expected to hear testimony
in the hush money
investigation on Monday.
And it's possible
then that it at least one witness
could be brought in before them.
Our sources tell us that
they are weighing whether to bring back
Michael Cohen.
But this is all part of the process
until we have a decision
from the Manhattan
District Attorney,
Alvin Bragg,
of whether he wants to move forward
and seek an indictment.
Former President Trump, John.
And as we wait to see where
the grand jury goes,
House Republicans
served notice
that they want to talk to Alvin
Break the Manhattan D.A.
They wanted to interview him.
He sent word back this morning,
sort of a defiant letter back to
House Republicans explaining
yeah, John Alvin Brooks sent
a letter back to House
Republicans telling them
that this was an unprecedented inquiry
into a local investigation.
He also said
that it was not a legitimate basis
for Congress to inquire.
I mean, he's really drawing the lines
here between the federal seat of Congress
and his office here in Manhattan,
a state office
saying that
this letter
that the congressman sent trends
into territory
very clearly reserved to the states.
His office said
that they would like to have a meeting
with the committee
to see what it is exactly
that they're looking for. John.
We'll watch and see
if they can reach a compromise
as that plays out.
And we know you'll keep watching
the grand jury action Carrasquillo.
Appreciate that very much. Thank you.
Let's get some legal insights
now with me at the table,
the former federal prosecutor,
Eliot Williams.
Grand juries are,
by their very nature, secret.
So we don't know a lot about this.
We don't.
We thought they were at the end.
Now it looks like they at least
are having a reassessment.
Maybe some new witnesses next week.
I want you to listen here.
This is the former chief deputy
under the previous attorney
general, Cy Vance.
But the same office saying she thinks Mr.
Bragg is doing this differently. Listen,
I think
they're having a little mini trial
in the grand jury.
Grand juries are usually
what they call bare bones presentations.
You put
a small amount of evidence in
because the proof is much smaller.
You just have to have probable cause
that a crime occurred.
But this is
a much more fulsome presentation
that makes sense to you, the idea
that if you're going to
have that rendezvous
with history
we talked about the other day
and put criminal charges
against a former president
for the first time in American history
that you treat the grand jury
essentially as a mini trial.
You know, it's a good way
to get your evidence out there.
Try it out in front of people
who are hearing it
and work through some of the problems
in the case.
You know, like
like she'd said,
they're you know,
the grand jury exists to build charges,
an investigative tool for prosecutors.
But they have to know
and going in and coming out
that they get their cases prosecutable.
And it may be
what they may be doing is rolling out
what could be
somewhat of a challenging case.
So, you know,
there is some merit to that.
But again, by law,
like I said, John, by law,
what happens in the grand jury is secret.
It's not just you know,
it's not just an honor system.
You can get in serious trouble
for leaking details
come out of a grand jury.
Quickly,
Alvin Bragg's
point to House Republicans said, I'm
in the middle of a local investigation.
Why are you asking me to testify
before Congress?
He says it's out of line.
Is he right?
He's absolutely right.
And to be clear,
Congress has vast oversight.
I testified in front of Congress
a couple of weeks ago about this.
And Congress is vast
oversight authority
but what this is,
is a local investigation
of local misconduct
from a private citizen
in the form of the former president.
Now, look,
he's the most famous person
possibly on the planet one of them.
But Congress really doesn't have business
trying to tell local prosecutors
how to do their jobs.
Stay with us.
We'll move on to another big development.
As we note, in Manhattan,
the prosecutors are regrouping.
But here in Washington,
there's some important forward momentum
in the special counsel's Mar
a Lago classified documents case.
A federal appeals court siding Wednesday
with prosecutors.
That ruling now
compels Trump attorney Evan Cochran
to answer questions
in front of a grand jury.
That ruling agrees
with a lower court judge
that the special counsel,
Jack Smith's team
can essentially tear down
the firewall around
attorney client privilege.
Because prosecutors did show
evidence of Trump using his lawyers
to commit crimes.
CNN Sara Murray
joins us now live with the latest here.
Sara, it's a big deal.
It is.
It's a really significant win
for prosecutors.
Obviously a blow to the former president.
I mean, just,
you know, the first hurdle
from the lower court
saying there is enough evidence
prosecutors presented us to signal
that Donald Trump
may have committed a crime
and used his lawyer to do so.
That's a blow.
And obviously the appeals court
siding with the lower court
is a second blow.
So Evan Corcoran
is going to have to go back
before the grand jury.
He's going
to have to answer more questions
our understanding is
that is scheduled for Friday,
but he also has to hand over
a bunch of documents.
Those include things
like handwritten notes.
They include transcripts of verbal
audio notes.
And this really gets to the heart
of conversations
he was having with the former president.
Remember,
this is someone who is really in
the thick
of the classified documents mess.
When Donald Trump got that subpoena
last spring.
Evan Corcoran was one of the people
who helped
conduct the search at Mar
a Lago for any documents
or classification markings.
He was the one who wrote that statement
that was later
handed over to the government
saying, you know,
we've done this diligent search,
the one that Christina Bob signed,
and there's no more
classified documents on the premises.
Obviously,
when the FBI showed up and searched
Mar a Lago. That was not the case, John.
Not the case.
Sara Murray,
appreciate that important update.
Elliot Williams
still with us at the table.
So piercing attorney client
privilege is a big deal.
You have to reach a high bar
of credibility there.
You think it's even more consequential?
We're talking about the notes here
because what you're trying to do
was Donald Trump using his lawyers
essentially to lie to the government
about what
he still had in his possession.
Right.
People lie Notes don't lie.
The words that people write down
in the
moment are a valid and useful record.
And so, yes, it is absolutely useful
for them to turn over whatever paper
or documentation he has at the time.
But again, like you
said, John, it's so profound
because they have
presented evidence that they believe
that the former president
committed a crime.
And that's
now the second time that's happened
once in California and once here.
That is significant.
That is significant. Again, Mr.
Corporate supposed to testify tomorrow.
We'll see what it's
grand jury,
but we'll see what we can learn
about that.
Let's talk
now with Shan Wu,
a defense attorney
and former
federal prosecutor, and also Laura
Baron Lopez,
who is a White House
correspondent for PBS NewsHour.
So, Shan, you have Alvin Bragg,
the Manhattan D.A., responding
in a blistering way,
as we were talking about
to these House GOP chairman
saying that what they want
his office to do is illegal or House
Republicans asking for something
illegal here.
Yes, they're completely overstepping
their authority here.
It's very hypocritical
that the party of states rights
is trying to ride
roughshod over New York
state's sovereignty here.
First of all,
even if this were a federal criminal
investigation, Congress
really would have no business
sticking their nose in it
because it's active.
It hasn't even been charged
yet at this point.
Then when you add in the fact
that this is a state
criminal investigation,
they really just have no basis for that.
The letter is blistering
and it's kind of funny to it's
will tone of humor there
because they're saying, well, to extend
your asking about federal funds
being used here,
we're writing a separate letter
at the legend, though,
how the federal funds are being used
because that's the
the early slightest hope they have
of jurisdiction over this,
the tiny, tiny hook.
So, Laurie, you have Joe Manchin, right.
Who's kind of an outlier
here, Democratic senator
with very particular politics
in West Virginia,
warning
that the court system
shouldn't be seen as getting involved
in politics,
but largely Democrats
have been pretty quiet
on these Trump legal issues.
What is their thinking here?
That's right, Brianna.
Democrats writ large,
as well as President Biden
in the White House
and the White House writ large,
they don't want to be seen
as trying to interfere at all
in these investigations.
Agents that whether it's
the investigation in New York
or the DOJ's investigations
regarding classified documents
or January six
and the end Trump's efforts to overturn
the election results,
they don't want to touch it at all
because they want to show
that these are
independent investigations,
which they are.
Republicans on the other hand,
particularly a growing number
within the House
GOP, have decided to really send a signal
with these investigations,
which right now are just based
solely off of Trump's
comments earlier this week, which is that
if you investigate
or try to hold the former
president accountable
for potential wrongdoings
and criminal acts
then the House GOP is going
to investigate those investigators.